hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm answering a question from
one of my newsletter readers Manuela who
is a makeup artist and she's invented a
makeup bag product that helps keep
makeup cool so what she found was when
she's doing her makeup outside for her
clients it's really hot that makeup
starts to melt that doesn't perform as
well as if you can keep the makeup cool
so she invented this bag to help to help
keep things cool she wanted my advice
and if it was a good idea and how to
start executing on it so Manuela I'm
obviously not your target market don't
use makeup and you know don't need a
makeup bag to keep it cool but you
obviously have to start talking to your
demographic the first question I would
have is looking at as an owner or an
investor in this business is what is
your market are you able to target a
mass market is this something that every
woman would want to buy is it a big
enough problem that every woman who goes
out and it's a hot day needs to have
their makeup you know in a cool place or
is something that only people in your
industry so people who are makeup
artists would be in student buyer so
that's kind of the first question that
you need to resolve so something my wife
would be interested in or something just
for makeup artists and then you can
price it accordingly so if it's in if
she's specific it'd be a lot more
expensive if it's mass-market you can
bring the price down to be able to reach
more people and interest more people in
the product the next thing I try to
figure out is can I go up to one big
customer to make a lot of orders or do I
have to go out and sell these things one
at a time
most people think when they're starting
the business to sell these products one
of the time the consumer market it's a
really really hard way to great business
a better way is if you can target a
business customer or a bigger customer
who can make you know an order for a
thousand of these at a time ten thousand
or more just depending on how many
people you know are in the organization
but can you sell to a big company that
would want to buy this on behalf of
their employees or as a giveaway to know
customers that they have trying to make
those sales can bring cash in the door
and you can also build your product
around the challenges that they
may have specifically to them so you
might have to design the bag in a
certain way to help accommodate certain
products you know they might have
specific needs that they they're asking
you for you can put a logo on the bag or
whatever it is but if you can design
around the customer then you have money
coming into your business and it's
sizable money it's not one-off selling
to consumers but you know they're making
orders hopefully at least in the
hundreds so it's a great way to be able
to kind of get that business off the
ground the last thing we do is try to
find influencers so people who are in
your market who can be a source of you
know influence and can recommend your
product so it's great that you are your
own target market you understand the
needs of makeup artists it's fantastic
to kind of build around the problem
there who is the most respected makeup
artist in the world and can you get them
to use your product and endorse it or
their celebrities who you don't need
their makeup with them all the time and
they can potentially recommend your
product or is there an industry
association for makeup artists that you
can show your product to and get them to
endorse it so look for people who if
they said it was a good product other
people would listen to them so it's a
lot easier to go out there got one
person and have them influence many
other people than for you to try to
reach all those many other people by
yourself so hopefully that helps so you
know look at how big your market is is
it just for makeup artists or is there a
bigger market try to go out there a big
customer and get them to place at least
hundreds of orders and then look for
influencers to see who can help
recommend your product and promote it
for you so hopefully that helps many
well if you guys liked the video please
give it a thumbs up I love seeing those
come in and I'd also love to hear what
you have to think if you have any other
advice to mind well as well if you want
to leave a comment under the video and
stay tuned for next episode
you